gary received a ton of congratulatory
tweets and emails unfortunately it was
because mma fighter conor mcgregor threw
out a worse pitch than
gary
i got some tape of gary on the wrap-up
show talking about his first pitch it
still haunts him to this day it sounds
like he's dramatized
i can't remember the last time i threw a
baseball like if i see a baseball i'm
not picking it up i'm so
mentally repelled by it that i don't
even think i've i may not have thrown a
baseball since that pitch it's very
possible you're that traumatized
i am i am and i know you guys think i'm
being a [ __ ] for it and everything like
that and um i just you know it's ever
all even as you're talking
right and i do believe i do believe you
guys are coming from a good place even
as you're talking
i can already feel the pressure
i can already feel the pressure and i
don't need that pressure in my life
anymore
wow
the pressure of what as they're talking
i'll tell you so here's what's going on
so rassan and john
for like two years now keep telling me
that
just i need to go back out throw the
pitch again but it's going to be a big
story of redemption
and it can't be any worse than it was
that even if i do it's bad and i'm like
i just don't want to do that anymore and
i do think yeah no you shouldn't
hey i agree who told you the first time
not to throw the first pitch
yeah
i said gary there's no upside if you
throw a decent pitch no one cares you
throw a bad one you're gonna have to
live it down the rest of your life i i i
begged him
yep you're you're right he's never he
but he knew better it's my life my
lifelong dream both well you got your
dream
you got your dream now you got that turn
your dream turned into a nightmare
nobody to blame but me he can't handle
the pressure but he has to let it go at
some point and just say well that
happened rather than i can't i can't let
it go these guys keep bringing it up now
i didn't let it go all right
you